oh merde
ça c'est un cobra
ah ouais ouais ouais oh il est
énervé
[Musique]
calme le secret
je suis en Inde la terre démarre à Jah
de Gandhi et d'Eric chou
le deuxième pays le plus peuplé au monde
après la Chine
1,3 milliards d'habitants
l'Inde c'est aussi le pays des serpents
si ils sont partout dans les maisons sur
les toits sur les terrasses dans les
canalisations
ils peuvent mesurer plus de 5 mètres
les Indiens les respectent et leur voix
véritable culte
certains en font même leur animal de
compagnie
mais dans le pays les serpents tuent 50
000 personnes par an c'est la moitié des
décès du haut morsure de serpent dans le
monde
moi je déteste ça
d'une de mes plus grandes phobies mais
je vais devoir y faire face
pendant 7 jours je vais partager le
quotidien des irulsaces une communauté
de chasseurs de serpents il les traque
jour et nuit pour pouvoir récolter leurs
penins un poison qui vaut une fortune
jusqu'à 200 000 euros le litre
on en fait des antidotes et des
médicaments contre le cancer
grâce au bonheur les iroulas ont réussi
à conserver leur mode de vie
traditionnel
je vais suivre ces chasseurs de reptiles
qui risquent leur vie tous les jours
je vais aussi traquer la vipère de
Russell
attends attends une des vipères les plus
mortelles au monde
j'assisterai à l'extraction du venin une
opération délicate info mouvement et
c'est la mort assurée
pour comprendre la culture et le mode de
vie des iroulas je vais me mettre en
danger
désolé
ça c'est quoi c'est un mauvais serpent
un mauvais serpent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis à Chenay
la quatrième ville du pays
[Musique]
6 millions d'habitants
une fourmilière humaine et un joyeux
bordel routier
il faut avoir les yeux partout pour ne
pas se faire écraser
[Musique]
avant de partir à la chasse je préfère
savoir exactement ce que je risque en
cas de morsure
direction un des meilleurs hôpitaux de
la ville
j'ai rendez-vous avec un médecin
spécialisé qui soigne chaque année des
dizaines de personnes mordus par des
serpents venimeux
comment allez-vous ça va merci moi c'est
Sébastien je suis le docteur coumann
alors je vais suivre des chasseurs de
serpents
j'aimerais savoir ce qui peut m'arriver
les morsures de serpent sont très
dangereuses parfois elles peuvent tuer
les gens sur le coup
ce qui se passe le plus souvent c'est
que la peur elle-même peut tuer les gens
les morsures de serpent provoquent deux
choses immédiates la première c'est que
ça libère de l'hémotoxine et sa cause
une hémolyse une destruction des
globules rouges avec des saignements
immédiats
donc vous commencez à saigner de toutes
les parties de votre corps
les yeux le nez la bouche
ça bloque la circulation sanguine vers
le cerveau
le cœur tous les organes arrêtent de
fonctionner et c'est la mort
ouais ben en fait il m'a pas du tout
rassuré
merci merci beaucoup
c'est la première nuit je n'ai pas
encore vu un seul serpent et honnêtement
je ne suis pas pressé
krishn mon chauffeur a bien compris que
je n'en menais pas large
[Musique]
il me conduit dans un temps
[Applaudissements]
ici on vénère Shiva une des divinités
les plus importantes et les plus
respectées de la mythologie hindouiste
tous les chasseurs de serpent de la
région passent dans ce temple pour lui
demander sa protection
on appelle ce rituel un pujat
le prêtre va me recevoir mais avant ça
je dois acheter un plateau d'offrande
[Musique]
tous les cas ça sent bon
tu les gardes pour les dieux
merci c'est combien
ça suffit merci merci
je te demande de protéger ton hôte et
d'écarter les dangers qu'il trouvera sur
sa route
je suis protégé des serpents
maintenant que je suis immunisé j'ai
accès au bosquet sacré
un lieu de culte entièrement dédié aux
serpents juste derrière le temple
des dizaines de totems en argile les
représentent dans leur milieu naturel on
leur offre du lait et des fleurs en
signe de respect leur déesse a le
pouvoir de protéger les hommes
Naga
c'est la protectrice des serpents elle a
des serpents partout autour d'elle tu
vois cette représentation où ils
s'entrelace
on appelle ça le troisième œil ou l’œil
de l'âme c'est pour ta connaissance
intérieure
pour être plus stable
c'est traditionnel
mais toi tu en as pas religieux
mais c'est une bonne chose que tu es ça
ça rend ton esprit plus équilibré
bon bah si j'ai l'esprit plus équilibré
ça devrait bien se passer
[Musique]
deuxième jour ce matin je me rends à
autignabaka un petit village à deux
heures de route de chez naï
j'ai pris avec moi mon collier de fleurs
on ne sait jamais
[Musique]
dans ce hameau les 2000 habitants sont
des iroulas
cette communauté chasse les serpents
depuis plus de 3000 ans est la même
réussi à les dompter au fil des siècles
[Musique]
historiquement les iroulages chassaient
les reptiles pour revendre leur peau
mais en 1972 le gouvernement indien a
interdit cette pratique
depuis il capture les serpents pour
revendre leurs venin c'est l'unique
gagne-pain de ce peuple de paria
[Musique]
j'ai rendez-vous avec Cali et à lamelou
les meilleurs chasseurs du village
bonjour monsieur bonjour
je m'appelle Sébastian enchanté je suis
content de vous rencontrer bonjour
bonjour comment allez-vous
vous êtes déjà prêts
un petit peu
vous ne mettez pas de chaussures
moi j'ai mis des grosses chaussures
parce que j'ai peur
ils sont mis sur leur 31
[Musique]
pour trouver des serpents il suffit de
sortir du village et de s'enfoncer dans
le premier champ venu
[Musique]
il n'est même pas 7 heures du matin
il fait déjà 30 degrés
le terrain est idéal pour les reptiles
qui aiment la chaleur et l'humidité
[Musique]
ce qui me fait le plus peur c'est de pas
aller voir parce que c'est moins
inquiétant une fois qu'ils sont attrapés
ce qui les contrôle mais c'est de me
balader là
dans les feuillages
j'aime pas du tout
je rentre pas là-dedans
moi je ne sais pas quoi ça ressemble
mais a priori c'est dans la terre
je comprends mieux pourquoi elle a pris
sa barre à mine
[Musique]
je le suis dans des
endroits où je m'étais juré de pas aller
peuvent être n'importe où là
[Musique]
tu passes par tout faire par les pires
c'est pas vrai quoi
au milieu de ces épineux je me rends
compte qu'à tout moment
je peux marcher sur un serpent
c'est fou quoi
les maisons sont juste à côté
nous longeons la rivière les cobrass
font souvent leur nid près des cours
d'eau
ça leur permet de boire mais aussi de
s'enfuir en cas de danger
ce sont de très bons nageurs hors de
question que je mette un pied dans l'eau
je vais découvrir que les Cobras ont
d'autres facultés et ça ne va pas me
rassurer pourquoi il regarde en haut
pourquoi ils regardent ces bestioles
sont aussi de très bons grimpeurs
les serpents peuvent aussi être
au-dessus ouais
après 2h de recherche toujours pas de
serpents en vue
une bonne nouvelle pour moi mais pas
pour Cali et sa femme
qui ne peuvent pas se permettre de
rentrer bredouille
[Musique]
c'est quoi ce truc il est mort non
c'est pas un bon serpent
c'est quoi c'est quoi c'est un mauvais
serpent un mauvais serpent ouais il est
pas bon celui-là il est pas venu me
en fait laisse-le filmer
[Musique]
bon ben voilà maintenant vous savez que
même quand ils ne sont pas venimeux j'ai
une peur bleue des serpents
il est 13h nous rentrons au village les
mains vides sous une chaleur écrasante
la journée commence mal
je suis défoncé
je suis je suis je suis je suis je suis
je
être un peu présentable
Cali et à lamelou m'ont invité à
partager leur repas
en attendant
je vais me faire un petit break
[Musique]
le repas est prêt
végétarien
tu as déjà été mordu par des serpents
combien de fois trois fois
il t'a mordu la oui ici
ici et à la cheville aussi
et ça fait mal ouais ça fait très mal
c'est très très violent
ouais c'est très douloureux
très douloureux
qui t'a appris à attraper les serpents
c'est mon père qui m'a appris quand
j'avais 5 ans j'ai tout appris en
famille
c'est très fatigant quand on est petit
on partait chasser à 4 avec mes frères
et mes sœurs on a tout appris en famille
tu as des enfants ouais deux garçons
deux fils et tu leur apprends à chasser
le serpent non pourquoi ils ont peur ah
il flippe ouais ils ont peur
cet après-midi changement de stratégie
direction le cœur de la campagne
indienne à une heure et demie de moto
Dottignies
sur une vieille anglaise s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
pour info restez en vie sur un deux
roues dans le coin relève de l'exploit
[Musique]
notre zone de chasse est là-bas ok c'est
dangereux oui
maintenant notre terrain de jeu ce sont
ces rizières à perte de vue
[Musique]
un nid de serpent à ciel ouvert
sous une chaleur insoutenable
[Musique]
la zone est infestée de Cobra et autres
reptiles en tout genre qui s'y
nourrissent de batraciens et de petits
poissons
en Inde 80% des attaques ont lieu à la
campagne
l'an dernier dans ces champs 5
agriculteurs ont succombé à des morsures
de serpents
[Musique]
une fois que le serpent a mordu tu la
valves c'est ça et ça ralentit
l'empoisonnement ça ralentit l'action du
venin
traditionnellement
ça va être compliqué même punition que
ce matin il faut à nouveau se frayer un
chemin au milieu des ronces et des
broussailles
des bosquets séparent les rizières c'est
là qu'habite les serpents
[Musique]
il fait plus de 35 degrés
et je suis à bout de force
[Musique]
n'a plus d'eau
après 10 minutes de pause la traque
reprend là je commence à être pressé
d'en trouver des serpents
il y a des trous il y a des trous
partout il y a des
trous ce ne sont pas des terriers de
lapin ou de rongeurs
ce sont des nids de Cobra
ux
[Musique]
le saut du truc
le serpent par la queue à bonne distance
pour ne pas être mordu
les iroulas sont réputés et respectés
pour leur connaissance et leur maîtrise
des reptiles
un savoir ancestral qui se transmet de
génération en génération
ce Cobra mesure au moins un mètre 50
pour ne prendre aucun risque Cali
utilise un crochet à serpent
les cobras n'attaquent que pour se
défendre il se dresse sur le tir
supérieur de leur corps pour intimider
leur adversaire
les yeux dessinés derrière la tête sont
là pour déstabiliser les ennemis
[Musique]
pendant quelques minutes la fascination
pour cet animal va l'emporter sur ma
peur
grâce à Cali je vais réussir à
m'approcher à moins d'un mètre du
serpent
tu n'as pas peur
[Musique]
ok ok
là il est très en colère
il a très peur
il se passe quoi faut aller à l'hôpital
tu peux mourir si tu n'es pas soigné
dans les quatre heures tu peux mourir
sans traitement les gens meurent
le venin de certains Cobra peut tuer un
éléphant
son attaque est foudroyante plus rapide
qu'un clin d'oeil
Cali va m'en faire la démonstration avec
son chiffon
le serpent ondule en fonction des gestes
et des mouvements de qualité
il n'entend rien mais il a un odorat et
une vue hors norme
eh oh
il est nerveux oui il est nerveux il a
peur il a peur
pour ramener ce Cobra à la maison le
maître dans un sac en toile ne suffit
pas
il pourrait mordre à travers
c'est pour ça qu'il finira le voyage
dans un panier
OK
première prise mais sur le chemin du
retour la chance va nous sourir à
nouveau
ok ok
c'est un gros celui-là
[Musique]
ok ok ok ok
ce Cobra mesure plus de 2 m c'est un
mâle et il est moins docile
Cali a plus de difficultés à le
maîtriser
[Musique]
fin de journée pour leur doc Cobra quali
et sa femme toucheront 56 euros
l'équivalent de 15 jours de salaire d'un
ouvrier agricole
[Musique]
ce soir j'ai bien l'intention de
profiter de ma soirée
loin des serpents
[Musique]
mais en Inde même dans les restaurants
ça pique
c'est très bon
[Musique]
bon appétit
merci
on va essayer de terminer
c'est très pimenté
voilà ce qu'on mange
tu m'étonnes que les serpents se font du
féminin
[Musique]
troisième jour
ce matin direction le village de Mamala
pourra à 50 km au sud de chaînage
il faut compter deux bonnes heures de
route
[Musique]
j'ai rendez-vous dans le plus grand
centre de récolte de venin du pays
une coopérative dans laquelle travaille
tous les chasseurs et roulent de la
région
[Musique]
bonjour
comment allez-vous bonjour Comment ça va
bien merci
[Musique]
comment allez-vous je suis Sébastien
et le directeur de la coopérative depuis
7 ans c'est un ancien chasseur de
serpent
est-ce que vous pouvez m'expliquer où
nous sommes
la coopérative il roula c'est une
association qui regroupe les chasseurs
de serpent de trois districts de l'état
du tamis Nadou
il y a combien de chasseurs de serpents
dans cette coopérative
362 personnes les chasseurs attrapent 30
à 40 serpents chacun par an et il gagne
entre 400 et 500 euros par mois
on fournit à chacun des membres une
assurance en cas d'accident des aides
matériels des outils pour rattraper les
reptiles des paniers des sandales on
fournit tout le nécessaire
bigforts les quatre serpents les plus
mortels du monde le cobra le bon gars la
vipère de Russell et l'échine garrénées
mais pour préserver l'écosystème naturel
le gouvernement impose à cette
communauté des quotas de chasse
on a le droit d'attraper 8300 serpents
par an 2000 Cobra 1500 bons garantiens
2000 vipères de Russell et 2800 et 6
carénées ces quatre espèces ont les
venin les plus puissants ici on les
extrait et on les vend au laboratoire
pharmaceutique pour qu'il fabrique des
sérum anti-venin
[Musique]
depuis son ouverture en 1982 cette
coopérative a révolutionné la production
d'antivona en Inde
elle approvisionne aujourd'hui tous les
hôpitaux du pays pendant un mois la
coopérative garde les serpents dans ces
arbres le temps de prélever leur venin
puis ils sont relâchés dans la nature
pendant leur captivité
il faut les nourrir une fois par semaine
[Musique]
en Inde
il vaut mieux être un serpent
qu'une souris
[Musique]
pas le temps de souffler une nouvelle
partie de chasse m'attend
cette fois je pars traquer des vipères
mes anges gardiens Mutu et son oncle
rajedran sont des vétérans de la
coopérative on va attraper des serpents
oui
les serpents sont par là-bas
comment tu te sens j'ai peur
je crève de chaud dans mon jean mais
je m'en fous
Mutu traque les reptiles depuis 20 ans
son oncle ragiendrale depuis 35
comme tous les y roulas il chassent
toujours à deux pour des raisons de
sécurité
la capture des vipères de Russell est
encore plus risquée que celle des cobras
car elles n'ont pas peur des hommes
autre petit détail
leur venin est encore plus mortelle les
serpents sont près de l'eau oui
pour avoir une chance de les trouver
il faut s'enfoncer dans ses marécages
ils sont bien tranquillou
[Musique]
à l'endroit où l'on va il y a beaucoup
de vipères très venimeuses elles sont
toutes venimeuses oui et il y en a
partout il faut bien regarder où tu
poses tes pieds
des Scorpions aussi quoi
j'y crois pas
et Madame tranquille
c'est dans ces zones sauvages en bordure
de ville
que les morsures de serpents sont les
plus fréquentes
je peux prendre ça pour me protéger
Moutou et son oncle sont des lignées il
cherche en priorité les peaux mortes des
reptiles les vipères de Russell ne sont
jamais loin de leur MU
bonjour
[Applaudissements]
j'aime pas ça
[Musique]
une simple brindille suffit pour
vérifier la présence d'une vipère dans
son lit
Mutu et son oncle n'hésite pas à y
mettre le bras
non
j'y vais pas là
il y a des temps
mais pourquoi il souffre pas des temps
j'aime pas ça du tout
allez
j'aime pas
[Musique]
après 4 heures de recherche
nous sommes peut-être sur la bonne piste
il a mué
la vipère ne doit pas être loin
viens viens il a trouvé la vipère ou
attends attends attends
cette vipère presque invisible
c'est la pire de toute une vie paire de
Russell c'est une vipère de Russell avec
sa tumeur en trois heures
tu vas beaucoup transpirer tu vas avoir
mal partout et tu vas pisser le sang de
partout
tu peux voir le poison
il y a une goutte juste une goutte c'est
une femelle
avant toi before
[Musique]
pour attraper des rongeurs c'était notre
addition
aujourd'hui on capture les serpents
juste pour leur venin
5 heures une vipère
en même temps la vipère qu'ils ont
attrapé tu meurs en trois heures bon ça
va
grâce à leur partie de chasse Moutou et
son oncle gagne chacun 250 euros par
mois
pour la vipère de Russell qui viennent
de capturer la coopérative leur versera
18 euros
mais leur journée n'est pas finie ils
vont maintenant extraire le venin de
plusieurs reptiles
on appelle ça la traite des serpents
l'opération est périlleuse elle demande
concentration sans froid et savoir-faire
première étape fabriquer le récipient
pour récolter le poison avec un verre et
un morceau de cuir
deuxième étape
attraper la tête du serpent
c'est la phase la plus délicate
et enfin dernière étape
le fer mort
il faut traire 4 serpents pour obtenir
un millilitre de venin
une fois récoltée il va être transformé
en poudre et congelé
il servira à fabriquer des sérums
anti-venin et des médicaments contre le
cancer
une dose d'antivenin coûte en moyenne
150 euros
ici c'est le labo et en principe
l'entrée est interdite
on n'a pas le droit de rentrer
mais vous nous autorisez cette pièce
c'est la banque de la coopérative
ça c'est la machine qui transforme le
venin en poudre le velin oui on en fait
de la poudre
c'est quoi
ça c'est du venin de cobra
ah ok vous l'avez fait
et vous utilisez la poudre oui la poudre
est utilisable pendant 12 ans alors que
le venin liquide c'est périmé en 30
minutes
il y en a un gramme pas
impossible de filmer l'intérieur du
frigo c'est le trésor des hiroulas
à plus de 200 euros le gramme de vola en
poudre il y en a pour une fortune
ragendra redoute un braquage
après une semaine avec les chasseurs de
serpents je n'ai pas encore réussi à
dépasser mon angoisse
si je veux exorciser ma peur une seule
solution
sauter dans la fosse
je vais essayer d'attraper des serpents
tout seul
et mon apprentissage commence par
celui-là ça c'est une échelle une quoi
une vipère et chide
et c'est dangereux très très peu
j'aurais beau essayer je n'y arriverai
pas
tu vas essayer avec un autre
deuxième essai
avec un serpent plus gros
il n'a plus de venin
ah si il en a encore
je fais pas ça avec le cobra
je le fais pas
je le touche juste
je ne fais pas ça ok pas de problème
si si problème
en fait
le cobra je ne le sens pas du tout
c'est trop remuant pour moi
dernière tentative
avec un autre spécimen
ça c'est une vipère de Russell à la
fameuse vipère de Russell oui un serpent
très dangereux c'est toxique
[Musique]
je ne serai pas venu pour rien
j'ai enfin réussi à surmonter ma peur
mais juste du bout des doigts
[Musique]
depuis mon départ la coopérative a
extrait le venin de plus de 4000
serpents de quoi sauver plusieurs
centaines de personnes
pour la quatrième fois de sa vie Mutu a
été mordu par une vipère a priori il va
encore s'en sortir
[Musique]
Cali et à lamelou continue de risquer
leur vie tous les jours pour traquer les
cobras dans la campagne